hello everybody its Michelle from loud
muffin beauty science here you might have
seen the news that Hawaii has banned
some sunscreens that have been linked to
coral bleaching the two ingredients
are the organic or so-called chemical
sunscreens oxybenzone and octinoxate. Are
these ingredients that bad? should you
avoid them at the beach? should you avoid
them in your daily sunscreens? is the
ban supported by the science? that's
what we're talking about today: the
science behind sunscreen and coral. One
of the main issues facing coral is
bleaching and that's the main harmful
effect that's been linked to some
sunscreens coral bleaching happens when
the coral turns white the stuff that
makes coral colored are microscopic algae
called zooxanthellae these algae and
coral live in a symbiotic relationship
it's a beneficial live in partnership
the algae live inside the coral and they
play an important role
they absorb light from the Sun and
photosynthesise and the nutrients that
they create provides the coral with
about 90% of its energy but when the
coral gets stressed
that's when bleaching happens the algae
leave the coral leaving the coral white
and bleached without the algae the coral
don't have their main source of food and
so they'll slowly starve to death
bleaching can be reversible if the
stress goes away then the algae can go
back to the coral and everything is okay
again but if there's too much stress or
if the stress goes on for too long then
the coral stays bleached and eventually
it dies there are lots of different
stresses that can cause coral bleaching
the main ones are temperature changes
particularly the higher temperatures
that are associated with global warming
from climate change
there's also ocean acidification when
the pH of the ocean drops because
there's too much carbon dioxide again
this is related to climate change they
might also be increased visible and UV
light from the Sun and also if there's
too much pollution for example
herbicides fertilizers from farming oil
spills and dirt
relatively recently it's been discovered
that some sunscreen ingredients can also
cause bleaching the studies were
conducted on isolated coral pieces of
coral were placed in a bag and the
sunscreen ingredients were added to them
here are some of the studies Danovaro
and co-workers found that hard corals
were bleached by oxybenzone, octinoxate
which is also called octyl methoxy
cinnamate or ethylhexyl methoxycinnamate
and enzacamene which is also known as
4-methylbenzylidene camphor or 4-
MBC they also tested some other
sunscreen ingredients and found that
they didn't cause any bleaching these
sunscreens were octocrylene, octisalate
or octyl salicylate and avobenzone
a 2014 study found that titanium
dioxide nanoparticles could also cause
slight bleaching a 2016 study from the
Haereticus laboratory by Downs and
co-workers found that oxybenzone causes
bleaching and deformities in multiple
coral species a 2017 study by Fel and
co-workers at L'Oreal found that octocrylene
octyl triazone,  ecamsule or Mexoryl
SX and drometrizole trisiloxane
or Mexoryl XL had no effect on coral
while
avobenzone only had an effect at a
very high concentrations. zinc oxide
caused bleaching in this study. in 2018 a
study by Corinaldesi and co-workers
found that uncoated zinc oxide
nanoparticles caused rapid bleaching
while modified titanium dioxide
nanoparticles had a minimal effect I've
put more details about each of these
studies in the blog post that I have
linked to this video and the links to
each of the studies are in there as well
it's in the caption now these studies
sound pretty worrying especially since
the bleaching happened even with really
low concentrations of sunscreen
ingredients we're talking parts per
million and parts per billion
concentrations but the amounts of
sunscreen in the ocean are also really
low so one of the key questions we
should be asking is is there enough
sunscreen in the environment to harm
coral?
first off we're going to have to talk
more about these extremely low
concentrations
there's extremely low and then there's
extremely extremely low here are some of
the numbers involved ppm means parts per
million or milligrams per liter this is
the equivalent of about 1/50th of a drop
diluted in one liter which is about a
quarter gallon for you US people it's
about this much
ppb means parts per billion or
micrograms per liter 1 ppb is a thousand
times more dilute than 1 ppm. ppt means
parts per trillion or nano grams per
liter 1 ppt is a thousand times more
dilute than 1 ppb and a million times
more dilute than 1 ppm a fundamental
principle in toxicology or the science of
how bad stuff is is that the dose makes
the poison the long version of this is
that everything can be a poison in large
enough amounts and everything is safe in
low enough amounts ppm ppb and ppt are
all extremely low and tiny to us but the
difference between ppm and ppt is 1
million so to go from 1 ppm to 1 ppt you
take your liter with 1/50th of a drop and
throw it into half of an Olympic
swimming pool this massive difference is
really important when we're looking at
the amounts of sunscreen in the
environment are the concentration is low
enough to be safe or are they high
enough to be harmful? in these studies
the coal was exposed to sunscreen in the
parts per million and parts per billion
range and while these are really low
other coral researchers have pointed out
that these concentrations are actually
much higher than the amounts of
sunscreen that you find in the vast
majority of the environment for example
the lowest concentration of pure
sunscreen filter used in the 2008 Danovaro paper that had an effect was about
1 ppm of enzacamene or
4-MBC one part per million sounds
really small but if you think about it
it actually turns out to be quite a lot
if you apply
30 grams of sunscreen which is the
recommended amount for an adult-sized
body and it has 3% enzacamene in it and
all of it washed off your body into the
water, to get one part per million you'd
be swimming in about 900 liters of water
which is only about three bathtubs full
to get 2.28 parts per
billion of oxybenzone one of the lowest
amounts tested in the 2016 Downs
study your 30 grams of sunscreen
containing 6% oxybenzone would have to
completely wash off in 790,000 litres of
water or about 1/3 of an Olympic
swimming pool these estimates are
actually on the high side since studies
have found that people usually wear less
than half the recommended amount of
sunscreen and the amount that dissolves
in water is a lot less than 100% one
study estimated that only about a
quarter of your sunscreen washes off
during a 20-minute swim the ocean is
also incredibly incredibly massive
ridiculously unimaginably mind-blowingly
massive it contains about 97% of the
world's water which is 1.34 times 10 to
the 21 litres that's about 200 times
more liters than there are grains of
sand in the world it's 70,000 Olympic
sized swimming pools for each of the 7.44
billion people living on earth
there are also ocean currents that mix
this water around so it shouldn't be
surprising that sunscreen is only found
in almost undetectable concentrations in
most of the environment that's in the
ppt range and a lot of the time it can't
actually be detected but in some
situations in some environments there
could be higher concentrations of
sunscreen that could realistically
affect coral generally this is in the
more enclosed bays in areas with lots of
tourists where there might be hundreds
of sunscreen covered people swimming in
a small area of water for example
there's been high concentrations of
oxybenzone measure near popular beaches
in the US Virgin Islands at Hawksnest
Bay and Trunk Bay
75 parts per billion and 1.4 parts per
million of oxybenzone have been measured
during busy times of the day there's
also a possibility that even though the amounts
in water are low bioaccumulation might
happen this is when the coral takes in
and collects the sunscreen ingredients
so they build up and form a much higher
concentration inside the coral so there
are only really low concentrations in
the environment although in some places
there might be higher but there's
another big question mark in the data
there isn't any solid evidence of
sunscreens having caused harm to coral
reefs yet some researchers have
mentioned that they've seen that coral
reefs in a few areas with more swimmers
are more degraded than in areas with
less swimmers or they're worse in areas
with more sunscreen use but this is
anecdotal evidence at the moment so it
isn't really convincing there could be
other factors at plays so for example
the tourists might trample on the coral
reefs so all the headlines that you
might have read that sunscreen kills
coral reefs oxybenzone causes major
damage to coral reefs the sunscreen ban
will save coral reefs this isn't what
the studies say some scientists have
tried to estimate the amount of damage
that sunscreens might cause to coral in
aquatic recreational areas in Hong Kong
near snorkeling hotspots it's been
estimated that the risk of bleaching by
oxybenzone is 21% and the risk of
bleaching by octinoxate is 11% a 2008
study estimated that 10% of the world's
reefs are threatened by sunscreen
pollution and this numbers been cited in
a bunch of other papers this sounds
pretty concerning but marine scientists
who research the wider causes of coral
reef damage say not so fast
a lot of marine scientist are actually pretty
critical of the sunscreen ban if we zoom
out and look at the wider picture it
turns out that the possible harm from
sunscreens is really really tiny in
recent textbooks and reviews on coral
bleaching sunscreens don't even rate a
mention instead there's tons and tons of
data showing that climate change and
agricultural management have wreaked
havoc on coral reefs and will continue
to do so
professor Terry Hughes a massively
respected coral expert and the director
of the ARC center of excellence for
coral reef studies says he would put
sunscreen all the way down and number
200 on a list of bad things that humans
can do to coral reefs he points out that
the worst coral bleaching is happening
in areas where tourists don't go so for
example in the massive 2016 Great
Barrier Reef bleaching event the worst
bleaching by far happened in the remote
northern region where and the severe
bleaching patterns matched the areas
with higher water temperatures higher
water temperatures caused by climate
change
researchers Kelvin Gorospe and Austin
Humphries at the University of Rhode
Island also say that the damage from
sunscreen is negligible when you look at
how climate change threatens coral reefs
they say that if you want to do
something to save the reefs in the ocean
you shouldn't be worrying about
sunscreen banning sunscreens to try to
save coral reefs is a bit like
rearranging deck chairs on the Titanic
or polishing a scratch on your doorknob
when your house is burning down yes
technically every little bit helps
but is it worth spending time and effort
and resources dealing with sunscreen
when there are much much bigger issues
to work on and many of these scientists
think that it's actually a bit of a
sneaky trick by politicians to hype up
the sunscreen issue it's an easy way for
them to show us that they're doing
something while distracting us from the
real issues climate change and
agricultural management which are much
harder to fix and something that their
corporate donors probably don't want
them to fix because it cuts into their
profits so they encourage us to think
that sunscreens are much bigger issue
than they actually are so that we might
get off their backs and ironically if
you're throwing out unused sunscreens
and driving around looking for the right
sunscreens with the right ingredients
you're actually making the climate
change problem worse okay so what can we
actually do to help the reefs firstly in
terms of sunscreen you don't really need
to do much except when you're planning
to swim in an area close to coral if
that's the case you should try to use
more sun protective clothing and stay in
the shade more so that you can use a bit
less sunscreen for the bits of your skin
that are still exposed you should look
for sunscreens that don't have
ingredients that have been found to be
harmful to coral the common sunscreen
harmful are oxybenzone, octinoxate,
enzacamene or 4-MBC and zinc oxide the
common sunscreen ingredients that have
been found to cause minimal harm or no
harm at all are octocrylene octisalate, avobenzone
octyl triazone, ecamsule
or Mexoryl SX
drometrizole trisiloxane or
Mexoryl XL and titanium dioxide the
sunscreen ingredients that haven't been
tested on coral yet are bemotrizinol or
Tinosorb S bisoctrizole or Tinosorb M
DHHB or Uvinul A Plus ensulizole
and homosalate there are lots of
brands that have coral safe sunscreens
in their range even if they don't say
coral safe so for example Supergoop
La Roche Posay Sunsense Stream2Sea
Coppertone and Headhunter it's
important that you actually check the
ingredients of the sunscreen and don't
just look for labels that say reef
friendly or biodegradable these terms
aren't regulated so they don't
necessarily mean anything so there's a
lot of sunscreens that say they're reef
friendly but might contain oxybenzone a
lot of sunscreen brands also assume that
all organic or chemical sunscreens are
harmful
while all inorganic or mineral
sunscreens are safe even though zinc
oxide has been found to be worse for
coral than many chemical sunscreens I
talk a little bit more about why I
think that it's not just nanoparticle
zinc oxide that harms coral in my blog
post so check that out if you're
interested in the nerdy nitty gritty
biodegradable also
doesn't mean reef safe both zinc oxide
and titanium dioxide are non
biodegradable since living organisms
can't break them down but zinc oxide has
been found to be harmful to coral in
some studies while titanium dioxide has
been relatively safe you should try to
limit how much sunscreen comes off your
body into the water as well look for a
highly water-resistant sunscreen and
apply your sunscreen 20 minutes before
you go into the water so it has a chance
to dry down and stick to your skin
better
the other big thing we should all be
doing for coral and for the rest of the
environment is to do something about
climate change
climate change is a huge and scary
problem but there are some things that
we can all do to help we can try to cut
down on our biggest contributors to our
own carbon footprints for most people
this is owning and driving a car going
on long flights and eating meat you can
also switch to an energy company that
uses green energy you can also vote for
political parties who firstly recognize
that climate change is a problem and who
have policies that actually tackle
climate change and you can contact your
local representatives about climate
change if you feel like your voice isn't
that important and you're just one small
person it might make you feel better to
know that because most people don't
contact them they assume that for every
one person who does contact there are
ten or twenty silent people who feel the
same way and that's all for today sorry
that was a bit of a depressing video but
the politics around climate change are
pretty depressing my next video is going
to be a lot more cheerful I've put the
link to the blog post for this video
with all the info and links to the
studies and further reading and
everything in the caption if you enjoyed
this video please like and subscribe to
my channel you can also find out more
about the science behind skincare and
other beauty products on my blog and you
can follow me on Facebook and Instagram
as well see you next time for more
beauty science